طبعا مشاهدينا هذا عن النوايا النوويه
لبعض القاده الروس ولكن ماذا عن استعدادات
الاوكرانيين المخاوف من سيناريو الحرب
النوويه تتزايد والملاجئ وايضا حقائب
الظهر واجهزه الراديو باتت هي الحل الوحيد
وذلك للنجاه اصبحت حقيبه
ظهر مضاده للاشعه النوويه مليئه بالمؤن
وادوات البقاء على قيد الحياه والعديد
ايضا من الاحتياطات الممثله اصبحت الطريقه
الوحيده التي يمكن ان يعتمد عليها
الاوكرانيون في حال نفذ الجيش الروسي ضربه
نوويه طبعا وفقا لتقرير صادر عن واشنطن
بوست فان العشرات من المواطنين
الاوكرانيين قاموا بتجهيز اقبيه وذلك داخل
المنازل منازلهم وحتى في اماكن عملهم
تحسبا لاي ضربه نوويه روسيه وبدرجات
متفاوته يفكر سكان كياف في الاحتمال الذي
لم يكن من اليوم يمكن او من الممكن تصوره
السابق بان مدينتهم يمكن ان تكون مستهدفه
بقنبله نوويه طبعا بالنسبه للعديد من سكان
اكيف فان المخاطر الروسيه كافيه لتبرير
بعض خطط الطوارئ حيث تم تجهيز نتحدث عن
حوالي 425 ماوى اضافي في كياب لخدمه اولئك
الذين يعيشون خارج المدينه
الملاجئ لا يكون بها متسائل للجميع سوف
يقوم باغلاق ابوابها قبل خمس دقائق من اي
انفجار متوقع طبعا لحمايه من بداخلها من
تداعيات الاشعاع الواشنطن بوست ايضا اشارت
الى ان كيف تمتلك بالفعل شبكه من الملائكه
الجاهزه للطاقه النوويه في شكل نظام مترو
الانفاق الخاص بها والتي تم تشيدها في
الحقبه السوفياتيه والموجود على عمق 346
قدم تحت الارض
[موسيقى]